Anna played 5 golf games
and its lowest score is 80.
The results of the first 4 games and the lowest game
are shown in the following dot diagram.
We see this here.
Its lowest score is 80,
as she scored 90 once, 92 once,
94 once and 96 once.
They found that Ana violated some rules when she noted
80, so this result - I guess it's a fraud attempt - has not helped her
and will be removed from the data set.
They took this out 80.
We only have the results of the other 4 games.
How will the removal of the lowest result affect?
Median and Median?
Let's actually think about the median first.
The median is the average number.
Here, when she had 5 data points,
the average data point will be that,
where we have 2 left and 2 right.
So the median here will be 92.
The median is 92.
And what is the median after they have removed it?
You now have only 4 data points.
When you try to find the median
of an even number of numbers,
you look at the middle two numbers.
These are 92 and 94.
And then you get their average.
You go midway between them to find the median.
So the median here will be ...
Let me write it a bit clearer.
The median here will be
half between 92 and 94, which is 93.
So the median is 93.
The median is 93.
Therefore, remove the point with the lowest score
in this case increases the median.
So the median - I'll write it down here.
The median grew slightly.
The median is growing.
But what will happen?
with the mean value?
One of the approaches without having to do
any calculations, is to get the number,
which is lower than the current average,
I have not calculated the current average value.
But if you remove it, the average value will rise.
The average value will rise.
I hope this gives you some idea.
If you remove a number that is greater than the average,
then the average will be reduced,
because you will not have that big number anymore.
If you remove a number that is lower than the average,
then you will not have that small number,
which will reduce the average and so the average will increase.
But let's check this mathematically.
Let's calculate the average value here.
We will collect 80, plus 90,
plus 92 plus 94 plus 96.
These are our data points.
And this gives us: 2 plus 4 is 6, plus 6 is 12.
And then we have 1 plus 8 is 9, and that is,
this is 9 and then we have another 9,
another 9, another 9, another 9.
In essence, here are 5 nines.
So this will be 452.
This is the sum of the results of these 5 games.
Then we divide it into the number of games we have.
So this will be 452 divided by 5.
452 divided by 5
will give us ... 5 is contained,
it does not fit in 4, it is contained in 45 nine times.
9 by 5 is 45, subtract, get 0,
Download the pair below.
5 is contained in 2 zero times, 0 in 5 is,
0 by 5 is 0, subtract.
You have 2 left, so you can say that the average value here,
the average value here is 90 and 2/5.
No 9 and 2/5, but 90 and 2/5.
So the average value is somewhere here.
This is the average value of these data points there.
And if we remove this, what will be the average value?
Here we will only have 90 plus 92,
plus 94, plus 96, we collect them together.
Let's see 2 plus 4, plus 6 is 12.
And then we collect those, and we get 37.
372 divided into 4 because I now have
4 data points rather than 5.
4 is contained in ... Let me do it
where you can see it.
4 is contained in 372,
is contained in 37 nine times.
9 by 4 is 36, you get, you get 1.
We take the couple down, it is exactly three times.
3 in 4 is 12.
There is no remnant.
So median and average value here
are both, this is also the average value.
The average value here is also 93.
You see that the median,
the median rose from 92 to 93, it grew.
The average value was 90 and 2/5 to 93.
So the average value grew more than the median.
Both grew, but the average grew more.
It makes sense because that number was
at a great distance below all those here.
You can imagine that if you remove it,
the average will increase a lot.
But let's see which of these answers
are what we have just described.
Both the average and the median will decrease, no.
Both, the average and the median will rise,
but the average will grow more than the median.
That's what we saw.
The average value was 90 and 2/5 or 90.4,
rose from 90.4 or 90 and 2/5 from 93.
And then the median rose by only 1.
Here is the right answer.